I like prefacing things with it's really
expensive before I say the price and I
like doing that because no matter how
rich someone is expensive always means
expensive like so it's expensive and
it's like they brace themselves and then
you say it if they imagine a number
higher it's a relief if they imagine a
number that's high but we're still
higher they were braced for it and so
then you don't have these big reactions
if someone's like I've never paid more
than $1,000 I'm like yeah and you're
here today the biggest advantage that we
all have and anything they've bought is
that they're here they clearly didn't
work so like everyone's from
everything they've done in the past they
have such a disadvantage cuz they
reached out to us from like a leverage
perspective they want you to sell them
they're just like say something else